As we saw in the quiz before this one,
when we multiplied y^4 times y^-2, we used our
short cut to say that this is just equal
to, of course, leaving the x^2 there,
y^4-2 power. The role that this -2
exponent here plays then, is that it makes
it so that, in the final answer, which we
know is x^2y^2, we have two fewer y's
multiplied together than we did in at
least this first part, the y^4 factor of
the original expression. But how do you
write y^-2 in terms of multiplying some
number of y's together. Well if we know
that y^4xy^-2=y^2.
And also, we remember that y^4 is four ys
multiplied together. And similarly, y^2 is
two ys multiplied together. This y^ -2
needs to cancel out two of these other
four ys that are multiplied together, to
give us our final answer. Now, we know
that the way that we undo multiplication
is division. y^4 needs to be divided by
y^2, to equal y squared, we can write this
out like this. We have four y's multiplied
together, divided by 2 y's multiplied
together, and each of these y's in the
denominator cancels out one of the y's in
the numerator, since everything here is
just multiplied together. This is how we
end up with just two y's multiplied
together. Together, since we can see that
we only have y times y left on the left side. If
we just look at this way of writing our
expression though, we can write both the
numerator and the denominator in terms of
exponents. So, on the top, we still have
y^4 and the bottom of our fraction we have
y times y, which is just y^2.
So, if we move this way where an
expression appear to be end up with
y^4 times y^-2=y^4/y^2.
We see this factor may be not we so need
to multiply this pair x ^ 2 to get a final
answer. In this answer choice right here,
y^4x^2/y^2.